all right here now with reaction former
senior advisor president Trump Stephen
Miller Fox News contributor Tommy lahren
and the author of The soon to be
bestseller trial of the Century Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett Greg
why don't I start with you you can
respond to Congressman Comer also to the
news at John Solomon tonight which is
big in my view
yeah if the accusation against Biden is
true and there's evidence to support it
seanick constitutes the crime as you
point out of bribery under federal law
as well as a separate felony under the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act which
makes it a crime to use your public
office to confer a benefit on a foreign
entity or government in exchange for
something of value money but beyond that
it rises to the level of impeachment the
Constitution specifically States the
president can be removed for treason and
bribery so representative Comer is Right
given all the other compelling evidence
of Biden influence peddling schemes it
should surprise nobody that there may
exist this Smoking Gun document hidden
in the vaults of the FBI linking Joe
Biden directly to a quote unquote
criminal scheme involving the exchange
of money for policy decisions Hunter
Biden's laptop is filled with similar
lucrative deals selling access to his
dad and Promises of future influence so
you're right to ask the central question
will Comer be able to get his hands on
it or will the doj and FBI Stonewall and
obstruct well given their shameful track
record they may refuse to cough it up
claiming oh it's now up classified after
the fact that's a common trick to
conceal damning records so Stephen
Miller we had the IRS whistleblower uh
immediately thereafter you get all these
Rumblings if you will of an indictment
of Hunter Biden is that a coincidence uh
now we have another whistleblower coming
forward and apparently now they're
talking about Vice President Biden and a
foreign National and money Changing
Hands money for policy decisions uh it
seems like these whistleblowers are
doing a lot of good work for the country
yes well I salute the whistleblowers who
are standing up to expose this
corruption and this wrongdoing that is
threatening our national security and I
salute James Comer whose doggedness and
determination in Pursuit Of Truth is
nothing less than extraordinary let's be
very clear Sean if Biden's Department of
Justice refuses to provide James Comer
with every single document he is seeking
and if there's any Defiance of that
subpoena that Merrick Garland must be
impeached that's without question
because that is obstructing the will of
Congress to get to the heart of the
question of is Joe Biden compromised by
a foreign power is he putting the safety
and lives of the American people at risk
to pad the bank accounts of the Biden
family so if garland does not cooperate
into the entire body of the
administration stonewalls this You Begin
by impeaching America this is a
fundamental matter of whether or not the
highest office in this land is bought
and paid for by a foreign power we must
get all the facts shot every detail must
be known and must be made public uh wow
Stephen Miller powerful Tommy let me go
to you and I want your take on that but
also the important story Tony blinken's
you know set up this uh Intel operation
and now we have Mike Morrell uh telling
John Brennan oh we need to give Joe
Biden a talking point to push back on
Biden laptop story and it turns out that
none of them knew a thing and they
signed this document anyway
to me that selection interference
well it is and Sean I know you have a
great studio audience there in New York
City I'm not average but exceptional
Americans
and how can they and all of us not feel
completely punked by all of this
completely punked we've got our law
enforcement and our intelligence agency
is not working on behalf of the American
people but working on behalf of
Democrats we've seen it with Hillary
Clinton now with the Biden crime family
how does the average American not look
at this and feel completely and totally
screwed over by these agencies that's
supposed to have our best interest in
our national security at heart and
another thing that really concerns me
when we're talking about the laptop and
the payments to the Biden family If This
Were maybe one payment it would be bad
enough but everyone needs to realize
this is not one payment these are
several payments spanning years what did
this family what did potentially our
president then vice president have to
give up to keep getting these payments
year after year after year in huge sums
that's what I really want to know
because the heart of our national
Securities at stake here and every
American should feel cheated and feel
lied to when does it end who's going to
be arrested who's going to be impeached
I think the American people are so sick
of this evidence piling up year after
year and nothing happens
Steve Miller Greg Jarrett all in your A
game tonight thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else